wir brauchen wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern sie sollen für uns die
welt erforschen und verstehen damit
unsere gesellschaft davon profitieren
kann gesellschaftlich ökonomisch
technologisch und für viele viele
weitere aspekte
deshalb lassen wir uns die ausbildung
von forschern viel geld kosten ich habe
deswegen immer angenommen dass alles
dafür getan wird dass im wissenschaftler
seriös und gründlich forschen können
aber inzwischen musste ich meine
annahmen ganz schön ab denken und ich
finde ihr solltet auch bescheid wissen
denn es geht nicht nur um unsere
steuergelder sondern auch um die zukunft
unserer gesellschaft und für den einen
oder anderen von euch vielleicht auch um
die ganz persönliche zukunft in diesem
video sprechen wir über die karriere und
die arbeitsbedingungen der forscherinnen
und forscher in deutschland über die
systemische ausbeutung ihrer liebe zur
wissenschaft den extremen leistungsdruck
den sie ständig ausgesetzt sind und die
prekären arbeitsbedingungen unter denen
sie und ihre familien leiden das hier
ist unser erster blick auf die dunkle
seite der wissenschaft
tausende wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler seit jahren total dieser
rahmenbedingungen arbeiten
und das ist ein problem was sich über
dicke sachen chance in deutschland
erstreckt
wenn man eine karriere an der uni
beginnt wird man teil einer globalen
gemeinschaft forscherinnen und forscher
gehen zu internationalen konferenzen sie
publizieren im internationalen
fachmagazinen und beteiligen sich an
internationalen kooperationen und es
gibt viele anreize sich häufig eine neue
arbeitsstelle zu suchen in einer anderen
stadt oder sogar in einem anderen land
dieser globale talent und ideenaustausch
ist sicherlich einer der gründe für den
erfolg der modernen wissenschaft dieser
fokus auf mobilität hat aber auch seine
kehrseite und dazu kommen wir gleich wir
haben also eine globalisierte
wissenschaft auf der einen seite aber
auf der anderen seite haben wir auch
regional unterschiedliche gesetze regeln
und gepflogenheiten allein in
deutschland haben bund länder und unis
jeweils ihre eigenen ziele und
verantwortungsbereiche und auch
stiftungen und andere geldgeber haben
einfluss und das ist so gewollt es soll
vielfalt in forschung und lehre
gewährleisten auch entwickeln
unterschiedliche fachbereiche wie zb die
astrophysik oder die neurobiologie ihre
jeweils eigene kultur weil sich themen
und methoden unterscheiden oder weil es
ein kleines oder ein großes fach ist um
über die akademische karriere in
deutschland sprechen zu können haben wir
uns statistiken angesehen die über alle
fachbereiche gemittelt sind und wir
haben uns die regeln und gesetze
angesehen die für alle oder zumindest
die meisten gelten und was wir dabei
gefunden haben ist ein akademisches
karriere system das der wissenschaft
mehr schadet als es ihr hilft wie dieses
system aussieht das erklären wir jetzt
das karriere system der wissenschaft ist
so angelegt dass man zwingend eine
professur anstreben muss wenn man
wirklich für immer in diesem beruf an
der uni bleiben will also ich sag immer
nur uni damit meine ich aber natürlich
alle hochschulen und auch die
sogenannten außeruniversitären
forschungsinstitute also jegliche
öffentliche forschung dass man unbedingt
eine professur anstreben muss ist
politisch so gewollt hat aber viele
schädliche auswirkungen schauen wir uns
doch mal den part an der zur professur
führt nach dem bachelor und dem master
kommt da erst einmal die doktorarbeit
dann wird man post doc und schließlich
kann man sich auf eine professur
bewerben wer ist dann endlich zu
professor geschafft hat kann die
privilegien des amtes auskosten dazu
gehören die verbeamtung auf lebenszeit
und zumindest prinzipiell das im
grundgesetz festgehalten recht auf freie
forschung und lehre aber es gehören auch
viele pflichten und jede menge
verantwortung zum job der größte haken
dabei es gibt viele bewerberinnen und
bewerber auf sehr wenige stellen dazu
später mehr also wir haben eine
vorgegebene karriereleiter die man
erklimmen muss klare vorgaben sind ja
eigentlich was schönes aber schauen uns
doch mal die details an wie sie zum
beispiel die bezahlung aus das steht im
tarifvertrag öffentlicher dienst kurz
oder tv.de aber das ist nicht wirklich
viel kürzer für doktoranden und postdocs
gilt die entgeltstufe 13 eine volle
stelle beginnt demnach bei rund 4000
euro brutto und das ist nicht schlecht
vielleicht nicht so gut wie die
aussichten in der privatwirtschaft aber
es ist definitiv mehr als die meisten
menschen hier in deutschland verdienen
wenn man eine volle stelle hat denn
doktoranden werden meist nur in teilzeit
angestellt nämlich für 65 prozent der
zeit der rest ist freies studium
das sind dann nur noch 2670 euro brutto
also in den meisten fällen so um die
1800 euro netto
das entspricht in etwa dem median gehalt
hier in deutschland wie viel prozent
einer vollen stelle man bezahlt bekommt
hängt übrigens nicht von der befähigung
oder der erwarteten leistung ab sondern
vom wettbewerb einfach dessen
absolventen auch ohne doktortitel einen
hoch bezahlten job in der wirtschaft
bekommen würden bezahlt auch den
promovierenden mehr
die teilzeitregelung für promovierende
hat die deutsche forschungsgemeinschaft
festgeschrieben die neben dem bund in
deutschland die meisten drittmittel
verteilt und an ihren vorgaben
orientieren sich in der regel auch die
meisten anderen institutionen übrigens
viele promovierende werden gar nicht von
den unis bezahlt 2009 10 waren zum
beispiel 15 prozent über stipendien
finanziert und weitere 15 prozent der
promovierenden hielten sich mit
arbeitslosengeld und anderen
sozialleistungen oder mit der
unterstützung von der familie über
wasser die größte gruppe sind aber die
angestellten promovierenden die werden
meistens für 26 stunden pro woche
bezahlt erwartet werden dann aber 40 das
sagen auch die meisten wissenschaftler
mit denen die regelmäßig sprechen aber
es wird ja der doktortitel da kann man
ruhig ein paar jahre lang zurückstecken
oder auch ein paar jahre mehr wenn
durchschnittlich brauchen doktoranden
anderthalb jahre mehr als vorgesehen
nämlich viereinhalb statt 3 und das
obwohl sie trotz teilzeit einstellungen
voll arbeiten zusammen mit den anderen
wissenschaftlichen mitarbeitern ohne
doktortitel kommen sie so auf
durchschnittlich sechs bis vierzehn
anhalt überstunden pro woche oder 41,7
arbeitsstunden natürlich ohne ausgleich
freies studium und so aber mit
unbezahlter mehrarbeit ist und
doktoranden nicht allein unter post docs
sind immer noch acht bis neun
überstunden pro woche normal und
professoren selber geben
durchschnittlich sogar an 55 stunden pro
woche zu arbeiten
der rest der bevölkerung kommt übrigens
durchschnittlich auf 4 überstunden pro
woche 9 bei führungskräften also
insgesamt deutlich weniger
jetzt mal ganz gut gefragt warum machen
die das natürlich geht niemand an die
uni um reich zu werden stattdessen
lieben die forscherinnen und forscher
wissenschaft wollen möglichst viel
spannende forschung machen und sich die
chance erarbeiten möglichst für immer an
der uni zu bleiben und dazu muss man wie
gesagt professor werden aber die chancen
auf eine professur sind gering 2010
wurden in deutschland 70 tausend
bewerbungen auf professuren eingereicht
eingestellt wurden aber nur 3000 im
gleichen jahr wurde übrigens 28.000 neue
doktor titel vergeben also streben die
forscherinnen und forscher vom beginn
der promotion danach zu lernen was man
als professor können muss und punkte auf
dem lebenslauf zu sammeln ein professor
muss zum beispiel lehrern also
beteiligen sich die doktoranden und
postdocs oft über ihre verpflichtungen
hinaus an der betreuung von bachelor und
masterstudenten in kursen seminaren und
bei ihren abschlussarbeiten und postdocs
betreuen natürlich auch noch
promovierende für den lebenslauf braucht
man aber vor allem fachartikel oder
aufsätze die ihren international
anerkannten wissenschaftlichen
fachmagazinen veröffentlicht werden
zusätzlich soll man auch seine arbeit
auf konferenzen und workshops vorstellen
und sich natürlich erfolgreich auf
fördergelder und auszeichnungen bewerben
all das ist extrem zeitaufwändig und da
es um die angesehenen fachmagazine und
die angesehenen förderprogramme und die
angesehenen auszeichnungen natürlich
viel konkurrenz gibt sind die
erfolgschancen entsprechend niedrig so
geht viel arbeitszeit für abgelehnte
anträge drauf aber man tut das alles ja
für sich selbst für die eigene karriere
ein ganz besonderer druck entsteht durch
die abhängigkeit der post docs und
doktoranden von den professorinnen und
professoren denn die bestimmen in den
meisten fällen wann die arbeit fertig
ist und wie gut die promovierenden
betreut werden aber für alle gilt die
empfehlungs briefe von doktor eltern
können karrieren richtig durchstarten
lassen oder auch beenden nein zu sagen
oder auch nur dienst nach vorschrift zu
machen dann vielmehr wird man ja
eigentlich nicht bezahlt kann man sich
in so einem arbeitsverhältnis oft nicht
leisten gleichzeitig profitieren die
betreuer und betreuerinnen direkt davon
dass doktoranden in ihren arbeitsgruppen
als teilzeitkräfte bezahlt werden dabei
aber mehr als voll arbeiten ein schelm
wer hier von interessenskonflikten und
ausbeutung potenzial spricht aber auch
als professor kann man sich nicht auf
seinen lorbeeren ausruhen also man kann
prinzipiell schon weil man ist ja
praktisch unkündbar aber die meisten
arbeiten sogar noch mehr als zuvor sie
haben das höchste leer pensum und auch
für sie ist prestige in der forschung
noch sehr wichtig man will also
möglichst häufig artikel in den
angesehensten fachmagazinen
veröffentlichen nicht nur für sich
selbst sondern auch für die lebensläufe
der doktoranden und postdocs die
außerdem auch betreut und gemanagt
werden wollen in vielen fachbereichen
gilt das motto publish or perish
veröffentliche oder stirb das erzeugt
eine abhängigkeit von großen
wissenschafts verlagen und die nutzen
die situation schamlos aus um tief in
öffentliche kassen zu greifen das ist
aber noch mal eine ganz andere dunkle
seite der wissenschaft und deswegen
wollen wir darüber separat in einem
anderen video sprechen dieses zweite
video und auch dieses video hier jetzt
schon sind aber sehr sehr aufwendig und
für diesen ersten teil hier konnten wir
tatsächlich keine sponsoren finden weil
es ein unangenehmes thema ist das ist
ein negatives thema und anscheinend
nicht so ganz werbe freundlich und genau
deswegen brauchen wir eure unterstützung
wenn ich finde persönlich dass es ja
wichtig ist dass über solche themen
gesprochen wird dass ihr darüber
informiert werden wie es da gerade
abläuft und genau deswegen wäre es echt
cool wenn ihr das geld habt dass ihr uns
auch paige ram unterstützt dort könnt
ihr uns monatlich mit verschiedenen
beiträgen unterstützen und bekommt dafür
zum beispiel videos früher zu sehen oder
könnte im abspann der videos genannt
werden und es gibt noch ganz ganz viele
verschiedene andere vorteile page und
procom / doktor watson damit wir
häufiger solche wichtigen videos machen
können dankeschön zusätzliche arbeit
entsteht weil die mittel der uni meist
unzureichend sind um all die
forschungsprojekte auch zu bezahlen
deshalb müssen laufend zusätzliche
fördergelder eingeworben werden die
sogenannten drittmittel selbst für die
institution direktorin an der berliner
charité ist das immer noch so christian
drosten beendete vor kurzem seinen
podcast um sich genau darum zu kümmern
und natürlich sitzen die professoren
auch in gremien und komitees engagieren
sich über die uni hinaus für die
internationale gemeinschaft geben
interviews für formate wie doktor watson
dankeschön und müssen sich bei allem was
sie tun auch noch mit der hochschule
bürokratie herumschlagen
der karriereweg wissenschaft ist also
lang anstrengend nicht so gut bezahlt
und eine professur winkt nur den
wenigsten aber wir sind mit diesem video
hier noch lange nicht fertig denn was
unsere wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler auf dem weg zur
profession noch zusätzlich beutelt ist
die permanente unsicherheit darüber wie
ihr leben weitergehen wird
ich schulde euch ja noch die antwort auf
die frage warum so viele forscherinnen
und forscher eine professur anstreben
sicherlich wollen doch nicht alle lehren
und eigene forschungsgruppen leiten das
problem ist dass eine feste stelle in
der forschung an einer uni fast nur mit
einer professur zu bekommen ist
ansonsten ist die zeit die man an der
uni bleiben darf begrenzt deshalb
arbeiten selbst die leute die lieber auf
der ebene eines postdocs bleiben würden
auf professuren hin in der privaten
wirtschaft wird vom gesetzgeber aus dass
ein normales arbeitsverhältnis kein
festgelegtes enddatum hat ohne
besonderen grund kann man ein
mitarbeiter deshalb höchstens für zwei
jahre befristet anstellen spätestens
danach werden sie fest eingestellt und
können sich halbwegs sicher sein dass
sie den job behalten aber für
wissenschaftliche mitarbeiter hat man
das einfach um zehn jahre verlängert
naja ich hab das richtig verstanden
wissenschaftliche mitarbeiter dürfen
zwölf jahre lang mit befristeten
verträgen hingehalten werden sechs jahre
lang vor der promotion und sechs jahre
lang danach und dann müssen die meisten
von ihnen gehen das problem ist aber
dass man nicht für diese ganzen sechs
jahren vertrag bekommt sondern für sehr
viel kürzere zeit
das ist doktor am reiber philosophin und
junior professorin an der universität
stuttgart sie hat gemeinsam mit doktor
christian eichhorn und doktor sebastian
kuban die initiative hashtag ich bin
hanna auf twitter gegründet unter dem
hashtag tauschen sich wissenschaftler
und wissenschaftlerinnen über ihre
arbeitsbedingungen aus und kritisieren
die aktuellen regelungen und die
initiative hat ganz schöne wellen
geschlagen also in der promotion ist der
durchschnittlichen vertrag zum beispiel
22 monate lang laut bundesgericht zum
wissenschaftlichen nachwuchs und die
promotion dauert im durchschnitt 5,7
jahre wenn man mal medizin
gesundheitswissenschaften aus und wollen
da sieht man schon da gibt es eine ganz
große diskrepanz also einen großen
unterschied zwischen der dauer die
eine promotion in anspruch nimmt und
eben der dauer eines solchen vertrags
also die allermeisten haben ganz viele
verträge während der promotion und auch
danach und das macht es natürlich sehr
unsicher und auch nach der promotion
geht es erstmal so weiter 2012 habe ich
angefangen zu promovieren und ich habe
seitdem eine ganze reihe von
arbeitsverträgen gehabt also allein an
der uni an der ich feuer bar in
düsseldorf waren es insgesamt acht
arbeitsverträge seit 2017 also das heißt
es waren immer so
teilweise zwei halbe stellen die ich
parallel hatte mal nur eine halbe stelle
die liefen zum teil noch ein halbes jahr
und dementsprechend war immer die frage
wie geht es denn eigentlich im jahr
weiter halben wo bin ich da kann ich
dann meine miete noch bezahlen und was
ist da eigentlich meine perspektive das
war immer schon ziemlich wackelig das
spezielle arbeitsrecht für die
wissenschaft geht also davon aus dass
alle professor werden wollen und
definiert selbst die zeit nach dem
doktor als qualifikationsphase dabei
haben die leute bereits zwei
berufsbildende universitätsabschlüsse
über vier jahre berufserfahrung und den
doktortitel der ihre qualifikation ja
auch noch verbrieft und das alles bevor
sie den post doc überhaupt erst antreten
und mit den promovierenden zusammen sind
es die post docs die den bärenanteil der
forschungsarbeit und einen guten teil
der lehre leisten diese regelung hat vor
allem zwei probleme
das erste problem ist dass promovierende
und postdocs in einen topf geworfen
werden und es wird keine rücksicht auf
die tatsächliche praxis in den
unterschiedlichen disziplinen genommen
die sich ja sehr unterscheiden können
und ein zweites problem ist dass dieser
qualifikations begriffs und ziemlich
schwammig gummiert er begriff ist so gar
nicht gesagt ist was damit eigentlich
gemeint ist man sollte eher ein denken
dass man das wort promotion steht und
dann hat man für die gesamte promotion
vertrag aber diese angemessenheit wird
im prinzip total aufgeweicht dadurch
dass man ein praktisch beliebiges
qualifikations ziel beenden die uni muss
also nur behaupten dass die forschenden
irgend etwas lernen können was ihnen in
der karriere irgendwie weiter hilft egal
ob an der uni oder in der freien
wirtschaft und schon kann sie die
anstellungen wieder befristen so
interpretiert das bundesarbeitsgericht
das wissenschafts zeit vertrags gesetz
kurzfristig vg und das bedeutet dass man
wissenschaftler eigentlich immer
befristet anstellen kann denn mal
ehrlich wie soll man so einen job machen
ohne irgendetwas sinnvolles zu lernen
von allen wissenschaftlichen
mitarbeitern und mitarbeiterinnen haben
81 prozent verträge auf zeit bei
promovierenden ist der anteil mit 93
prozent am höchsten dazu kommen wie
gesagt noch eine große zahl von leuten
mit stipendien oder welchen die sich
anderweitig finanzieren müssen das ist
ziemlich krass stellt euch mal vor in
einer firma würde man mit vier fünftel
aller belegschaft aus hochqualifizierten
fachkräften so umgehen wie mit azubis in
der probezeit nur weil sie noch nicht im
oberen management angekommen sind klingt
absurd aber so wurde es in der
wissenschaft wie handhabt für postdocs
heißt das nie wirklich sicher zu sein
wie es weitergeht deshalb versucht man
natürlich immer schnell irgendwas auf
dem lebenslauf zu bekommen bevor man
sich schon wieder eine neue stelle
suchen muss dabei ist das wissen vg
schon der versuch die zeitlich
begrenzten verträge zu reduzieren denn
vorher gab es noch weniger
einschränkungen für die befristungen
eigentlich so heißt es jedenfalls war
das gesetz dazu gedacht dass man diese
phase beschränkt und dass man dann eben
für die phase danach die leute
unbefristet anstellt das passiert aber
leider nicht stattdessen machen die
hochschulen und anderen
wissenschaftlichen arbeitgeber in das so
dass sie die leute dann halt für diese
sechs jahre maximal einstellen und wenn
diese sechs jahre erreicht sind dann
müssen die leute halt gehen und auch für
den übergang zur professur ist man sehr
kreativ darin die leute ohne
planungssicherheit hinzuhalten
doktorarbeit war selber ist zum beispiel
juniorprofessoren und damit befristet
angestellt es ist auch gar nicht
vorgesehen dass sie danach von der uni
als vollwertige professoren übernommen
wird wie es im sogenannten tenure track
system der fall wäre in der praxis heißt
das dass sie nach sechs jahren ihre
aktuelle uni verlassen muss und dann
muss sie halt gucken wo sie bleibt auf
diese art und weise gehen uns sehr viele
intelligente menschen in der forschung
verloren
aber warum will man die leute nicht
unbefristet anstellen in einem
informations video des
bundesministeriums für bildung und
forschung wird anhand der fiktiven
doktorandin hanna erklärt dass die
befristung der verträge verhindern würde
dass die ältere generation alle stellen
verstopft ja das ist wirklich der
wortlaut die jüngere generation solle
doch auch eine chance auf qualifizierung
bekommen diese fluktuationen würde dann
auch die innovationskraft erhöhen die
reaktion auf das video kam spät weil es
vorher einfach niemand gesehen hatte
aber als es dann auf twitter geteilt
wurde war der aufschrei laut und
deutlich unter dem hashtag ich bin hanna
kommen immer mehr berichte junger
forscherinnen und forscher zusammen die
von ihren prekären arbeitsbedingungen
erzählen insgesamt zeichnet sich ein
bild bei dem doktor war es zynisch
findet noch von chancen zu sprechen auch
das innovation stimuliert wurde darf
wohl angezweifelt werden die berichte
lassen da eher das gegenteil vermuten in
der privatwirtschaft wird das übrigens
auch offensichtlich anders gesehen dort
werden hochqualifizierte fachkräfte er
höher geschätzt wenn sie mehr erfahrung
haben die annahme dass man immer neue
leute braucht um innovativ zu bleiben
wurde außerdem nie wissenschaftlich
geprüft auch das offizielle gutachten
über die folgen des wissens zeit vorgeht
das geht es gerade ende mai
veröffentlicht wurde beschäftigt sich
überhaupt nicht mit dem thema innovation
sondern wiederholt einfach nur die idee
unbezahlte mehrarbeit
leistungsdruck abhängigkeitsverhältnisse
und existenzängste das sind sicherlich
punkte die man auch aus anderen branchen
kennt und das macht die punkte nicht
besser und hier hat man alle
gleichzeitig die vielen persönlichen
geschichten die unter dem hashtag ich
bin halt zusammen gekommen sind zeichnen
ein erschreckendes bild davon was das
mit den forschenden macht wieder kann
man hier von chancengleichheit sprechen
noch von bestenauslese die ständige
unsicherheit der enorme zeit einsatz und
die vielen ortswechsel mitmachen zu
können hat mit wissenschaftlicher
befähigung er erst mal nichts zu tun nur
mit privilegiert haid und wer zum
beispiel eine familie gründen will und
in genau dem alter sind doktoranden und
postdocs ja er kann und will sich solche
bedingungen nicht antun genauso geht es
denjenigen die gesundheitlich oder
finanziell eingeschränkt sind oder deren
aufenthalt in deutschland von einer
anstellung abhängt entsprechend sind es
derzeit vor allem die söhne von
akademikern die es zum professor
schaffen 60 prozent der jungen
professorin sind kinder von akademikern
und nur 34 prozent der neuberufungen
sind frauen wissenschaft ist und bleibt
ein beruf der privilegierten und dadurch
verlieren wir viele viele intelligente
köpfe die akademische karriere ist alles
andere als eine aufregende reise in die
intellektuelle selbst erfüllung und
materielle absicherung die liebe der
forscherinnen und forscher zur
wissenschaft wird vom pausenlosen
knallharten wettbewerb um den
beeindruckendsten lebenslauf und die
gunst der vorgesetzten strapaziert und
ausgenutzt und auch die forschung leidet
denn wo teamarbeit gefordert ist werden
nur persönliche erfolge im lebenslauf
gewürdigt wo extrem gut ausgebildete
fachkräfte gefragt sind steht die lehre
der karriere im weg wo intellektuelle
hochleistung gefordert ist werden
existenzielle ängste geschürt und wo
zeit und planungssicherheit gefragt sind
werden zu wenig gelder für zu kurze
zeitspanne angeboten man lockt junge
akademiker in diesem system von denen
die allermeisten irgendwann wieder
ausscheiden müssen und dann haben die
teils mehr als ein jahrzehnt an einem
lebenslauf gearbeitet der in der
privatwirtschaft überhaupt nicht gefragt
ist für mich war die recherche für diese
folge ein ziemlicher schock ich habe die
wissenschaft immer als strahlendes
beispiel für gute sinnvolle arbeit
gesehen die eben nicht kommerziell sein
muss aber am ende des tages macht der
druck des arbeitslebens auch hier nicht
halt unsere kritik soll keine zerstörung
sein sondern sie kommt von herzen wir
wollen dass die besten und hellsten
köpfe ungestört mit all ihrer passion
forschen können und wir lieben die
wissenschaft und deshalb können wir hier
auch noch nicht aufhören es gibt noch
mehr dunkle seiten der wissenschaft über
die wir reden müssen die sich bessern
müssen deswegen geht es in der nächsten
folge um den veröffentlichungs druck und
die macht der großen
wissenschaftsverlage abonniert gerne in
den kanal um das nicht zu verpassen und
wie immer vielen dank fürs zuschauen und
bleibt neugierig
das mit den noch einmal machen können
aber ich bin eine uhren wir können noch
einmal machen